so fast forward though now you live in
Austin now so you made that move to
Austin yeah what do you see that's
different about that Austin scene what
do you think like with Joe's Club being
built
what do you think what do you think it
can get to that place where it is like
the third biggest city for comedy I
think it'll be number one
I really really truly believe that
because I think that
um I mean I already see it I see the
amount of tickets that we sell casually
like like it's nothing like people are
just dying for it and waiting for it and
people are flying into Austin now when
they used to fly into LA and New York to
have a comedy weekend you know if they
wanted to see
you know
three nights of shows that's where they
would go but now words out syringes are
on the street porta potties on the
crosswalks in L.A you know about that
they just started putting porta potties
at the big crosswalks no yeah so like
you want to cross Hollywood and Vine
there's a porta potty there right next
to the button to cross the street and
they they ain't clean here's my other
Theory but is there enough comedians
that will there be enough this that's my
question because all right guys like Tim
Dillman have gone there and left yeah
Tim's there he's just waiting for Joe's
Club to be full-time Tim has more
property in Austin than anybody he talks
a lot of [ __ ] but he's like buying it up
really oh yeah dude he gets it Tim's out
here killing it and Segura and Christina
and me and Joe and Ron White and a whole
bunch of the the youth the future Danny
Brown you know Danny Brownie Brown yeah
no doubt I'm very close with Danny he's
my homie oh my God I just ate mushrooms
with him a couple weeks ago really oh
God people are coming to visit is that
those New Yorkers are that are real joke
Gunslingers we just had a tell on the
show on Monday he just did a whole
weekend in Austin and he's looking at it
with the twinkle in his eye like wait
what are you guys doing here this does
you guys do this every Monday and then
you do okay like and to any comedian
you know Comedy Store style you know or
comedy seller style they come to Austin
and they're looking at it
with like okay so maybe I'll spend like
a week out of every month here you know
we get Ari Shane and Norman there for I
know they love it four days a month and
Rogan's bringing good Comics down to be
on his show yep I mean that's what made
me think about it was like I would like
to go for a month and just have an
experience of it what does it really
feel like to be there go out get you a
sandwich get you a coffee get you a you
know you know find a wife or something
or see it and you know and do comedy at
night while you're trying to do that you
know and and have a you know like a
lifestyle of it I can't believe how much
I love it wow you know spending the
whole 15 First Years of my career in La
I never would have guessed that another
option would work
um I'm amazed at that too living here
yeah exactly you know and like all of a
sudden you're comfortable and you're a
little bit better rested and you have
maybe a new hobby or something something
to you know because I think in La it's
or New York perhaps it's easy to just be
like oh I gotta work I got to work it's
only about the next joke you know what I
mean I gotta I gotta but then you're not
living you're not experiencing things
you're not taking note you're not having
great conversations where you say
something that you realize might be good
on stage like living is a huge part of
what we do right I agree and I think one
of the things that's happened to
Hollywood over the years is it used to
be that people went people had these
like wild like people went there with
their energy and and like made their
dreams happen wrote scripts and but now
it's been so much like the Children of
Children and nepotism and you know third
generation screen right that it's like
the people writing the things and
creating the things they're not they
don't have as much life experience
anymore they're maybe their grandfather
did maybe their mother did but they're
still kind of riding off of those old
stories and energies so they're not as
tuned into some of the reality right of
of just like um of creativity really you
know another thing that I think is that
it's much easier for people to be
jealous and competitive there's a lot of
billboards there
I noticed that my last trip there I'm
like wow I just always
didn't notice like I mean the Billboards
were just part of like the skyline it
was just a tree it like Blends in with
LA
and as I'm looking up there I'm
realizing oh my God that show looks like
crap that show looks like crap that
movie I has it looks it tells its whole
script right there in the billboard like
and I'm judging these Billboards and I
realize like this whole place does that
to people like all of a sudden I'm
daydreaming about why does that idiot
have a show that's not gonna work wow
comedy Central's dead as hell you know
you're looking at the build itself yeah
and I'm looking at these Billboards and
I realize I'm thinking about this they
have me thinking about these things
which in Austin you can't there is no
like oh oh I wish I had that or this
person would be better for that or this
is where that should be like right so it
takes a lot of that business and the
jealousy and the like oh look at the it
takes a lot of that Glitz out of it and
stuff like that and also it's like these
people you know in LA and New York It's
the Last Stand because we've learned now
that the podcast is the way you can have
your own show and build your own fans
with people that are into what you're
into and like the sound of your voice
and want to hear it so that old model of
like all right let's throw this to the
people and see who likes it like it's an
old school model and it takes away from
the ability to build something and now
people are like well if I didn't start a
podcast now I can't start now I'm In Too
Deep now but it's like who knows it's
like Bitcoin or nfts or whatever like
who knows what the anything is yeah
well there are some things that are
great about La too though it's like the
weather is absolutely unbeatable you
can't beat it and there's no there's not
even any question about it I don't know
if there's anywhere in the world you can
beat the weather there yeah there's
barely any bugs there's no allergies in
the air no poisonous animals Jesus man
yeah a third of my childhood was filled
with [ __ ] poisonous animals dangerous
animals there are things that are great
about it the access to people that are
there is also nice like you know I have
friends like my friend James Blake lives
there he's a musician and he's like I
would have never got to meet him if I
didn't live in LA and it is kind of
name-dropping but he's also like one of
the most unique people that I get to
talk to like all of us and that would
have never met each other if we had if
it hadn't been for La oh yeah I'm
grateful for it just like I'm grateful
for Youngstown I think that you know
being from a place and living and having
the experiences of being in you know a
diabolical Place gets you to appreciate
everything that happens after that right
like you wouldn't be quite as P at peace
here in Nashville if you didn't know
that it takes an hour and a half
sometimes to drive from one gig to
another in LA or from the airport to
your house in L.A those little things
like here you get out at the airport
you're here in 10 15 minutes right yeah
same thing with me in fact I try to set
new records each time the airport's like
a place that now I have like great pride
and trying to get home in like seven
minutes or eight minutes it's crazy
um yeah I guess there's yeah there's
definitely a lot of things and it's also
like this is part of the journey it's
like
um you know uh communication like is
more free on podcasts and so it would
make sense that maybe they expand out to
different areas over time it's been
really interesting to be in a different
place and have access to different
guests and like unique people that
um normally may not have be able to get
on a certain platforms or weren't even
able to get on like kind of podcasts and
stuff so that's been uh really
interesting and kind of seeing like
what's who's the next person that I'm
going to get to meet that would be like
really really really awesome to have
come on from here like we got Mike Rowe
is going to come on right so I'm really
excited about that like I don't know if
I would be able to have him on if I
weren't in this area so
um yeah there's different things about
it and I can go back to LA whenever it's
always there it's still like you go back
The Comedy Store The Improv places that
I love the Laugh Factory has become
um it's it's still great uh it's gotten
better actually just busier over there
so the stages are still there
um and it's fun and yeah man when I go
back to the store it is a party those
are my people you know those people that
have worked there forever
um you know we're so close and we have
so much fun and it's like a reunion it's
like a different vibe instead of being
there all the time it's like you know
it's like going home and visiting you're
in a family yeah in a HomeTown
yeah
yeah it's interesting that is it's like
and we also have to be supportive of the
places we are it's like you you have to
do that like you have to kind of
champion where you are to an extent in
order to be able to survive there right
and um and have like a nice perspective
every day
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one